the fire fight has begun in Australia is
bracing for the worst Kangaroo Island
close to Adelaide in southern Australia
has already been devastated with
multiple deaths confirmed in Victoria in
the southeast they woke up to the now
familiar smoke
most people have evacuated Lake ties on
the coast but not all
we've sent away all our staff we sent
away our families just to be safe and
yeah we wanted to stay here and protect
this place your sons fighting the first
day yeah my boy Liam
works for the department of land and
water he's up at now now I gave him a
good huddle Huggle sorry like how can a
cattle this morning and cooked him
breakfast before he took off
it's worrying worrying you know like
that he's gone straight into the into
the mouth of it he's into the thick of
it no see he's 20
to the north a small town called now an
hour was under threat from a nearby
blaze the roads are closed but the water
stretch inland to the town so as we've
been heading up to now now it's just
coming up there we've seen the water
temperature increase were starting to
feel the radiant heat from the fire that
is behind the town now skipper says he
hasn't seen conditions like this the
wind is swirling about the visibility of
course very bad with the smoke the
temperature is increasing and on either
side you've got extremely dry bursts
this is potentially a very dangerous
combination we arrived to another quiet
town this strike team of firefighters
had been waiting for the worst but the
wind changed and the imminent danger
passed the fires are unpredictable and
fighting them sometimes about chasing
them a scale of the fires is stretching
resources on the ground and there are
clearly communities that need additional
help and in response to that we must
move forward first as a Commonwealth
particularly with the work of our
defense forces and then integrate with
the local operations that are in place
in those local communities
they're throwing everything they have
military helicopters included to contain
the fires today is about reacting as
quickly as possible
Tom Cheshire Sky News Lake tires
Victoria